amen is filthy rich man you can catch me
on bootleg Kev podcast it's filthy
bootle cat podcast live from the Super
Bowl Arizona shout out to Dutch air man
we got filthy rich in the building
what's good kid how you doing how are
you doing y'all here rap hustling as you
like to call it yeah rap hustling man
getting on the road get into a bag so
when you come to like obviously you have
a hosting tonight in town but when you
come to AZ for a weekend like Super Bowl
yeah
what is like the target like how many
verses you plan on recording this
weekend this [__] I don't know who's
gonna be out here uh I know you know
it's going to be a pack so see me
without see like I don't like me I could
just get on the road and just go
somewhere right and just post it just
post up post it on online
hit me for features shows right whatever
and they're gonna tap in videos that's
just something I built I kind of learned
that from Jack right you know what I'm
saying like he used to tell me that back
in the day like just come it's gonna be
good
you might you might not you never know
what you might run into like you might
run into a promoter that I've been
trying to book you I didn't have no
contact right somebody want to get a
verse from you um
[__] whatever we might it might want to
pay you to come to a meet and greet like
I I you know I come from the air I just
really like you know the independent
grind yeah I'm saying so it's kind of
easy would you pay for a feature in a
weekend like this if you run into the
right artist and they're like yo what's
up let's work let's listen right now
yeah no I ain't paying anything you
ain't paying nobody for a future no not
at this point like back in the day when
I first started rapping right yeah I'm
saying but I know everybody who who's
the most expensive feature you ever had
to pay for back in the day when you all
the features was the same price which is
what it was a dime 10 bands yeah okay I
ain't never pay no more than that that's
not bad yeah it comes with the video
this is like my early yeah early on what
year are we thinking when I first
started rapping just ran into [__] and
not no having no relationship let me
cash you out they have no problem it
wasn't even like that it's just like oh
man what's up like I'm trying to get you
on my on my phone yeah I know what it is
again I'm saying right I don't know him
he'll know me and it's just like the
same thing for me right
I mean I can't be biased about it you
know man people don't bought features
for me so if Jay-Z you running hope
Hope's like yo I got you just I need 25
bands you better do that for your Jay-Z
feature yeah listen that's that's
unbelievable run to the bank you don't
gotta run the bank but that's
unbelievable well frontier people it's
gonna cost more than that to clear that
dad for sure that's impossible so a
hundred percent you know I'm just I'm
putting out uh I mean I'm looking at it
like 25 000 is not a lot for Jay-Z so
it's like I feel like if he'd do it for
that he'll just do it for free if he
seen my if he seen my talent my work
ethic and like you know what I'm saying
like like a lot of people hit me up I
tell them my price so it's like people
to hit me up before and be like okay
I cannot give you this and I'm like nah
right I'm like hey if I'm gonna do it
for that might as well just do it free
uh you obviously have been building out
your label for a long time putting
together a dope roster artist yeah
really I just been focused this year on
that that's why I really haven't been
dropping too much music I've been
focusing on them getting all they
getting everything with them situated
and together so how many artists do you
have signed to you right now because I
feel like you got a nice a nice team oh
fods yeah 12 13 artists that's a lot of
people yeah so is it like obviously when
you sign an artist how much of it is
uh you know do you kind of feel like you
might be spreading yourself too thin are
you kind of are you signing
self-starters guys who are gonna go get
to it and then you kind of come in and
add yeah so like in the beginning we do
like artist development
we work and we building teaching them
how to you know um stop recording on
mixtape beats proper mixed Blaster and
[Music]
um
artwork yeah I'm saying all we we we're
getting it together and I got to really
see this is what you really want to do
first like you got to show me that
because you know tomorrow you might wake
up and say I want to rap no more or
whatever situation so it's like okay
cool I gotta know that you really
dedicated to this for me to
I came one more than you wanted this is
I I'm living my dream this is your dream
that I'm trying to help you you know
what I'm saying so with that being said
we'll start off like that and then as we
go towards that then we'll work into
bigger and better
most are is there like any are you
pretty much keeping your your roster Bay
Area oriented or just wherever I didn't
have artists outside of California uh
but as of right now
everybody like I've been just been
focusing on East Oakland he's Oakland
yeah on the hometown yeah it's kind of
uh kind of you know because I feel like
um
San Francisco's been changing so much
Oakland's been changing so much over the
last since the pandemic happened yeah
the [__] is kind of crazy like when you
go back it feels like there's like a lot
of energy has been
sucked out of certain parts of the Bay
do you feel like when you go back it
feels a little different sister I feel
like a pandemic obviously a lot of clubs
close a lot of spots closed it really
never was like you know really music
night scene in the Bay Area
um because like a lot of artists who
come in town and be like all right where
should I go tonight and there'll be
nowhere to go you know what I'm saying
so um it's kind of always been a thing
it has always been like that then I can
go to anywhere else and then got like a
night scene right like
the air you can't go nowhere like like
shout out to my boy book peso
um DJ Millions but I love
uh they've been doing anything
right now as in like um the hip-hop like
I would say like underground right right
right yeah I'm saying J12
[Music]
um
oh Drew Banger
um they've been they've been doing like
what they can do for the Bay Area
Oakland San Francisco like the
Underground Music scenes throwing
parties right again I'm saying um
bringing attention you know I feel like
the light on the city I was gonna say
Obviously you got a great relationship
with Ghazi uh as do I we both work with
Ghazi uh and he's so passionate about
kind of like the
keeping as much energy and resources
that he has going on in
you know in the Bay Area do you feel
that kind of similar responsibility of
course that's why I say I'm you know
focused on East Oakland yeah I'm like
okay cool I didn't I didn't work with
damn everybody in the bank so it's like
it's a lot of talent where I'm from so
let me focus on that first and then when
I'm done with it like you know what I'm
saying um you know spread yourself too
thin and take on too much but let me let
me um do my part yeah it's funny because
the last time I was in Detroit you were
in Detroit at the same time
um and you know it feels like Detroit
and the bay have a very uh
they have like a kinship with each other
yeah
um and you've worked with so many
artists out of the uh the d uh what do
you think it is about Detroit and the
Bay Area that it feels like they're kind
of their cousins the similar culture
um plus um you know in the past
um other artists from the bay I've
worked with Detroit you know but like
the the wave that's going on now with
the Detroit and Oakland the Bay Area
like I helped bridge the gap you know I
was really going out there
dealing with these artists like giving
them game and right connecting them with
guys and things that they didn't know
about music they was putting out videos
and doing millions of views but not
getting paid for it not having a song on
iTunes not having a song registered no
distribution just rapping like for years
they was doing that so they was getting
frustrated like
like man you know stagnated like with
the rap like I don't know how to get
money off of it like this video got five
million views on it I haven't been paid
it's [__] crazy you know what I'm
saying like underground hits like go to
the strip club
everybody in the club knows home
is that usually because the artist has
the song uploaded on or someone else
uploaded it yeah like it'd be like on
the director's channel right you gotta
understand like if you pay attention to
like the major labels they drop the
single first and then they drop the
video right and that's how it gets
registered you know what I'm saying
because the song's already out so it's
already kind of once someone uploads it
with that audio it will it'll flag it as
a as it belonging to you and they'll be
mad the cameraman thinking the cameraman
did something wrong and keeping their
money and right you know and [__] like
that but you know I mean you can't
remember if it's on the cameraman's
channel he probably shot it for free
most likely yeah or the cameraman is
probably even more popular than the
artist yeah he's got more subscribers so
it's like go ahead upload it on your
shoes artists didn't even have their own
YouTube channel right Evo channel you
know what I'm saying so it was just you
know giving you know helping people be
bosses and succeed and giving them game
or whatever and you know that's just it
like I've been doing that for years
outside of my artist I'm saying I've
never been a person to like you know
hold back information and be stingy
whatever it is like yeah I'm saying you
getting money I'm getting money that's
not gonna stop like I'm saying they
print this [__] every day like I like I
like to see everybody everybody Sean
what's up guys hey shout out to our
family at Bluetooth man and listen I
know we always are getting feedback
about our Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's their
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollars shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being a
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up
well go to bluetooth.com right now use
the promo code bootleg they're going to
send you a month for free they also just
dropped the mint chewable same active
ingredient as Levitra that's right so
what you need to do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks
and we got the hot Sox Basics baby yeah
so look so this was stuff about odd
stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg and you will save 20
off at checkout try the outsox basics if
you're one of those guys who wears other
plain white branded socks plain black
socks I promise you go with the odd Sox
basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro stand out and be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview uh
you've been known to do collaboration uh
projects who's somebody who's out there
that you're just a fan of that you would
you wouldn't mind doing a little mixtape
with
if you had your choice
um in La I've been rocking with my boy F
and peso we talked about it also big sad
and then uh right now I've been
listening uh Rico cash out of Atlanta
okay
shout out to Big sad
um for you like uh
coming from where you're from the
Independent grind yeah having
opportunities to sign with Roc Nation in
the past yeah uh I'm sure that wasn't
the only opportunity he had to go the
major route yeah
a major thing works for some artists
because some artists I think are kind of
lazy
I feel like it kind of there are artists
out there because I wouldn't say because
they're kind of lazy they might want to
work more but the label stops that so
like when you sign to a major like they
kind of don't
I want to say respect
but they kind of don't want you like
with the releasing it but they got to
understand like the culture you came
from also like how you also got to
understand how you got there yeah so
it's like they don't want they probably
want to drop an album tour for a year
dropped another album after that but
it's like a lot of artists like they
keep their buzz by working so like it's
a new artists come in every day so just
say you drop an album shoot videos put
out for a year then tour for a year
that's like two years by the time you
come back it's gonna be so many
different new artists out there in this
place and and if this artist came from
grinding they like oh he not that he
fell off but he just ain't being
consistent what's for you the reason why
you didn't end up doing the Rock Nation
thing they wanted your catalog right
yeah so they just wanted the back
catalog which is [__] how many albums
now I want to know but it was just from
whenever I release music how many albums
currently do you have out is it over a
hundred way over 100 Jesus way over but
uh I just didn't feel like that and
luckily I didn't do it and shout out to
them I disrespected them however they
run their business it's just that I
wasn't ready for it because of like a
lot of major artists I mean major labels
they could take you to make you to a
start
you know and put you on a bigger
platform in some artists want that
instead of won't you know games and they
want the fame over it right over like
the business part of the situation so
it's like okay they're jeopardized that
luckily I didn't do it because right
when I had that meeting Kofi hit right
after and that was that you're supposed
to be a tour going on that's your
residual income coming in off that
catalog sitting in the house doing
nothing right paying them for nothing
right you know what I'm saying so you
know but I mean it could have worked for
somebody else though because they was
talking about touring putting you with
this artist like what they do too
they have a lot of big already signed to
their labels right so or that they
manage and they'll put you with that
artist because you'll look good with
them and it'll be like this artist son
were they trying to put you with
um I mean it ain't too many that I
haven't been around I haven't been
around them all I know but when you're
with Roc Nation who are they like who do
they Envision put you with like who's
like you're in the sales meeting of the
pitch meeting where they're like yo we
think you're fit you'd sound great with
this guy are you fit if we play tonight
ain't nobody but we we talked about
different artists I work with but I know
how it works right I haven't seen it
done before yeah I'm saying so it's like
okay cool you got a label deal over
there you need artists and you're at
this label so we're gonna sign other
artists and then put this with you like
you signed them you know blow it up it's
all about look
anybody uh who you see doing the CEO
[__] as an artist that you really kind
of look up to or respect say Birdman p
um he just uh puffy
um yeah of course puffy
[__] all of them you know what I'm
saying
um camera
uh anybody that put they they people in
position you know what I'm saying even
if it was a fail even if it was
successful they tried right you know
what I'm saying so you uh have you been
noticing I would say have you been
noticing everyone selling their catalog
because they don't have to grind
they're sitting there I said now or they
don't know how to manage money so or or
understand like when when the pandemic
hit like a lot of them maybe were living
above their means and um
living off shows and we're talking about
like the Justin timberlakes the Justin
Bieber's of the world QC just sold for
300 million dollars like qcp yeah he saw
what the whole catalog QC guy just sold
300 million to Scooter Braun
[__] he's probably a crazy ass memory
you can't turn down I would have sold
that [__] too for 300 million but I bet
you if he sold it for 300 me I bet you
like the [__] is Right to Work like cool
like once you recoup that yeah they get
it back but like even if you say hello
it's not forever 300 I don't know I
don't know if I'll probably give you 300
million dollars it's me over here now
yeah you better put some news you better
put some new [__] out it all depends on
like how how structured the deal
structure every deal is different
because like you know like I heard like
if you say your catalog like it comes
back to you after a certain time or
whatever it's not forever so I don't
know listen man 300 million dollars yeah
this is me over here for perpetuity yeah
for sure I mean I'm sure he's going to
make not just 300 he's gonna okay like
he might make
600 and then
double backup they're talking about uh
Michael Jackson's catalog his family's
gonna sell half of it for 900 million
dollars but she's over perhaps excellent
Michael Jackson like every song on his
album used to be a single going Platinum
what I'm saying but it's just crazy it's
crazy to think that having songs on the
tape so his whole catalog's worth like
1.8 billion dollars
it's insane at that point in time you
just take the money like what else
you're going to do like what do you need
more money for yeah I don't even see why
they doing that I'm sure his music is
generating a lot of money how much money
is too much money like where where do
you just say okay we made it like we
give it two months we could relax
because no matter what like go on
vacation you're going to be working
you're going to happen do you go on
vacation
but my vacations be work like this is my
vacation now I'm chilling you're in
Super Bowl week in Arizona the next I
didn't come here for that I know but
that's what I'm saying I don't even know
this is not a vacation you're out here
grinding I don't even know who in the
Super Bowl Eagles and Chiefs okay I
didn't even come out here for that I
just came to work
so when do you go on vacation though
like you never go to like Cancun and
just chill yeah but I still work but
what are you doing in Cancun
[__] the Mexican rappers
pulling up on the back I'm still like in
tune to like what's going on with my
artists like man I made Cancun I throw
the flyer up guys I'm at Hard Rock
Cancun [__] I didn't see I didn't ran to
people everywhere that little [__] like
I mean I'm sure people probably do music
in Cancun right I don't we just went to
Hawaii are you allowed to go to Canada
yeah that's rough they don't play over
there huh and uh I got hit up got I hit
Drake oh that's Toronto man well Toronto
is in Canada
he has the pool yeah you'd have to yeah
for sure what's up y'all bootleg Kev
here hey look my bookie man it's a big
weekend in sports the big game is Sunday
Chiefs versus Eagles I'm all in on the
Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas Goddard
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you can do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip at
the beginning of the game all that right
now at my bookie sign up with the promo
code bootleg when you sign up they will
match your very first deposit up to one
thousand dollars with that promo code
bootleg so go to mybookie.ag sign up for
an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in they leave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
sign up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
a customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas uh what
else obviously you we were talking about
the label but for you uh what is coming
up for you man I just dropped the EP
um weekend in LA
uh
like last weekend for my birthday
assuming that was recorded on a weekend
in L.A okay yeah you know I got the week
in Detroit week in Houston we can I want
to do a weekend in New York try to do a
weekend in Phoenix okay but it's all
um La artists on the album listen man
there's some great artists here lame
song Chris Coke
who his name's Chrisco because who will
daily finesse they live in mercums
they're some amazing artists here I'll
put you on shout out to all in the Chris
Coke is hard yeah okay that's how I did
it like when I went to Detroit recorded
the music he went to Houston link up
with the artist in the city yeah like
the hottest artist out there right now
you know but I want to do one in New
York and then um like all my artists
like probably like four of them all
dropping in February [__] it's my um
Young Junior just dropped Skinny Tea
drop tomorrow how big is your team like
that helps you with all this stuff is
this really me and my product manager at
Empire
who's that now uh her name is Olivia now
oh shout out to live I live solid this
is just me and her every day that's it
huh
you should hire one more person well I
got an or I got air North I got my boy
in La matte black
um with Corey in Vegas and Oakland and
my boy Debo how is um the dog breeding
business
is it over with the pandemic over with
yeah because no one's got all that PPP
money to drop on their [__] exotic
Frenchies five six dogs a day Jesus oh
yeah one time where do you keep all of
the dogs I have bought a whole built the
whole dog like house like I spent like
250 like on a house like marble floors
AC yeah they had like stalls in there
glass you could see them through
Backyard Basketball Court
water well it was The Dark Side of
basketball court yeah it was it was nice
yes you know what I'm saying but who's
jerking the dog off
ain't that serious my boy in Vegas does
doesn't himself
they don't got time to go Las Vegas
money bullies look at him Ron Dizzle
loves jerking his dog I've seen a lot of
people do it like
I haven't been to a lot of different
places they put the dog down through
everything like take the semen out put
it in the girl put her to sleep soar it
back up and everything like right there
like at a house
that sounds like something like going to
someone's house to get a BB Hill yeah
that sounds wild crazy [__] okay we got
dog surgery in the garage we're getting
that much money off that [__] you don't
got time for all that like it's kind of
crazy too like with all the robberies
that be happening on these Frenchies see
me I'm taking mine as a shout out Dr
Bivins in Vegas that's who I go to man
he do everything are you worried like
like have you had anyone try to try for
one of these dogs no
that it's pretty hot out here I ain't
going like that yeah I feel like owning
a Frenchie is like a [__] security
Hazard now they believe they doing that
to like people they feel like you know
this gullible or pushover or something
like you know what I'm saying uh what's
the hottest dog besides a Frenchie if
you were if you were sorry English
Bulldog so English yeah I got English
Bulldogs but I just seen some new
some new Frenchies they got the new ones
in the fluffy they got like a rope like
a Sharpay like crazy you know they mix
with something but then even the um the
mutant dog even the um the fluffies are
mixed like all that [__] is like
genetics that [__] is probably mixed
with cocker spaniel or something Jesus
how does that work does they just make
these dogs [__] until they get something
cool like we figured it out so they they
it's just like it's like
okay they probably tried the first time
and it's just too too much so what
happens with those dogs and they stand
it out thin it out give those dogs away
do we put them down at the uh SPCA
somewhere so they thin it out into like
more of what they so like even though
William Billy is really like
an English bulldog in uh in the pit bull
so I got the pit bull ahead and the
English Bulldog body those poor bullies
man they just look uncomfortable
they're just like you can't see mine I
showed you mine shout out to bipolar all
this that's the father of my um you have
a boy right now that [__] is buff as
hell how do you get a dog buff it's got
to be in one of the genetics oh so you
don't like work out working out no they
just genetically like that like his arms
are just cocky like that geez and all
his pups you know that they're his yeah
wow shout out to him probably a terrible
father
I mean he don't even know all his keys
that's what I mean he's [__] up
bipolar is a bad dad anyway uh so you
say uh young Jr just dropped and J.R
just dropped Skinny Tea
um drought tomorrow fonte drop on the
25th dollar Dame drop on the 14. uh
that's all in February
uh and then [__] we got uh mad guy Debo
dropping on the third
uh little Steve dropping we working man
like you know if you were chewing me
then you're gonna be in tune with Jimmy
see what's going on
um just bang just dropped
my nephew J Money about to drop man this
is we working I ain't doing no plan
not gambling on the game obviously
because you don't even know who's in it
huh you're not gambling on the Super
Bowl so no no no no come on I don't get
one nothing I can't control
well then what do you gamble on oh I
used to gamble shooting dice you can't
control that myself I'm shooting days
but you can't control where the
dinosaurs
were you shooting with some loaded dice
no no I'm not gonna bet on the next man
I don't know okay yeah I'm saying that
God he might be having a bad day he's
like I only bet on myself and if I
provide the dice to the game no no no no
no no y'all gotta have to provide the
dice but the person that provides the
dice most likely be the one that lose
that's like the myth but um yeah
do you like playing craps in Vegas yeah
I can't just bet on
like if you plan today who I came better
you might be having a bad day you might
be arguing with your girl you might be
rigged they might pay you to to not
score or whatever I don't got time for
that you know I'm saying all right this
is do you watch sports
I don't really watch TV
nothing I don't think I've been watching
this uh BMF
and uh
Godfather or Harlow
shout out to Forest Whitaker that just
came back on I was watching snowfall
snowfall's coming back yeah [__] like
that you don't watch Yellowstone
uh what's on the other one not BMF uh
the other 50 Cent movie power power yeah
I feel like that well there it is filthy
rich we are in Arizona for the Super
Bowl who playing again the Eagles and
the Chiefs Patrick Mahomes versus Jalen
hurts okay see I'm gonna go with Casey
Man shout out Casey man I love Casey
yeah that is obviously a very uh
that's where Mac Dre passed away yeah
yeah man I was just out there man they
love me out there I bet they do yeah
it's like another Bay it is it is they
show love man for sure who you going
from
uh I mean I booked me but I booked Meek
Mill one night so I'm kind of hoping the
Eagles win you bet I do bet yeah yeah
I'm saying you better on the game I
haven't bet yet I haven't decided yet
man I just got into town last night so
the sports books are legal here they're
not legal in Cali yeah so I gotta I
gotta look at the lines you know I'm
gonna keep your money man I'm gonna
throw I gotta put a taste on it man I
just need a taste nothing crazy you got
you got Mika at 11 11. yeah I got enough
gambling happening with all the artists
that I've [__] booked this weekend
okay so the the Gamble's happening for
sure it's just it's not on the game
but yo man Filthy Rich appreciate you
pulling up brother appreciate you yes
sir we'll get back up in Cali soon boom